>> OF COURSE, SO IT'S A MOVE
THAT'S RAISING SERIOUS NATIONAL
SECURITY CONCERNS.
NEW TWITTER OWNER ELON MUSK SAYS
THAT HE IS GOING TO BEGIN
RESTORING PREVIOUSLY BANNED
ACCOUNTS NEXT WEEK.
THAT INCLUDES USERS BANNED FOR
THREATS AND HARASSMENT.
MUSK ANNOUNCED THE DECISION
AFTER CONDUCTING AN ONLINE POLL.
HE TWEETED, QUOTE, THE PEOPLE
HAVE SPOKEN.
AMNESTY BEGINS NEXT WEEK AND
THEN IN LATIN, THE VOICE OF THE
PEOPLE IS THE VOICE OF GOD.
JOINING US HOW IS CNN
INTELLIGENCE AND SECURITY
ANALYST BOB BAYER.
THANKS FOR JOINING US.
I'M CURIOUS TO GET YOUR REACTION
TO THESE ACCOUNTS BEING
REINSTATED.
>> I CAN TELL YOU ONE THING,
PUTIN WILL BE ALL OVER TWITTER
IF THERE'S NO REGULATIONS ON
THIS FAKE ACCOUNTS, SPOOFED
ACCOUNTS, THE REST OF IT, THIS
IS A GREAT OPPORTUNITY FOR HIM
AND SO WHEN HE'S TALKING ABOUT
THE POPULAR VOICE, MUSK, HE'S
TALKING ABOUT RUSSIAN
INTELLIGENCE.
THE RUSSIANS ARE WAITING FOR
SOMETHING LIKE THIS.
THEY NEED A PROPAGANDA CAMPAIGN
AGAINST THE UNITED STATES AND
AGAINST OUR SUPPORT FOR UKRAINE
AND THEY'RE GOING TO BE ALL OVER
TWITTER.
I GUARANTEE THIS.
SUPPORTING THE FAR RIGHT, PLANS,
DEMANDS TO STOP ARMING UKRAINE.
YOU JUST WAIT.
>> BOB, I'M CURIOUS TO GET YOUR
THOUGHTS ON THE COUNTER ARGUMENT
I'VE HEARD TO THIS BECAUSE A LOT
OF FOLKS SAY THAT THERE'S NOT
REALLY THAT MANY AMERICANS ON
TWITTER, BUT BIG PICTURE, THAT
KIND OF MISINFORMATION, THAT
KIND OF INFLUENCE CAMPAIGN CAN
HAVE A BIG EFFECT, RIGHT?
>> WELL, IT CASCADES, IF YOU PUT
UP DISINFORMATION WHICH THE
RUSSIANS WILL PUT UP, IT WILL
CASCADE EVERYWHERE IN INDIA, IN
EUROPE.
IT'LL APPEAL TO THE EUROPEAN FAR
RIGHT.
IT WILL APPEAL TO THE CHINESE
AND YOU'LL SEE THIS STUFF JUST
APPEARING EVERYWHERE.
YOU JUST NEED ONE PIECE OF
DISINFORMATION THAT IS SORT OF
HALF BELIEVABLE AND IT WILL GO A
LONG WAY AROUND THE WORLD AND
REALLY TRULY AFFECT OUR POLICY.
>> AND IT GETS MORE AND MORE
CHALLENGING TO DISCERN WHAT'S
REAL AND WHAT IS, YOU KNOW,
MISINFORMATION OR DISINFORMATION
WITH DEEPFAKES AND WITH THE
SOPHISTICATION BY WHICH SOME OF
THESE INFLUENCE CAMPAIGNS ARE
DEVELOPED.
HOW DO YOU DISCERN WHAT'S REAL
VERSUS WHAT'S FAKE EVEN, YOU
KNOW, IN LIGHT OF THAT
SOPHISTICATION?
>> WELL, THAT'S WHY THE PRE-MUSK
TWITTER HAD 7,000 PEOPLE GOING
THROUGH THESE ACCOUNTS, YOU CAN
PICK THEM OUT WITH ALGORITHMS OR
BY LOOKING AT THEM.
YOU CAN CHECK IPs AND THE REST
OF IT AND YOU SIMPLY BLOCK THEM
AND IT'S NOT RIGHT AND, YOU
KNOW, THIS FREEDOM OF SPEECH IS
JUST NONSENSE BECAUSE YOU CAN'T
GO IN A MOVIE THEATER AND YELL
FIRE, IT'S AGAINST THE LAW.
WHAT PUTIN WILL DO AND THE
RUSSIANS IS THEY'RE GOING TO USE
THIS AS A VEHICLE TO SAVE
HIMSELF AND UKRAINE AND, YOU
KNOW, WHETHER IT'S GOING TO WORK
OR NOT, I DON'T KNOW BUT WE'RE
GOING TO SEE AS SOON AS THESE
RESTRICTIONS COME OFF WE'LL SEE
THE RUSSIANS ALL OVER IT AS I'VE
JUST SAID.
>> SO YOU HAD AN OPPORTUNITY TO
OFFER A PIECE OF ADVICE TO ELON
MUSK OR TO COUNSEL HIM OR SIMPLY
TO SEND HIM A MESSAGE, WHAT
WOULD YOU SAY?
>> I'D SAY THIS LIBERTARIAN
NONSENSE IS DESTRUCTIVE TO
AMERICAN NATIONAL SECURITY AND
HE HAS GOT TO REINSTITUTE THE
SAME RESTRICTIONS THAT WERE ON
TWITTER BEFORE HE BOUGHT IT.
THERE IS NO OTHER CHOICE.
>> HE DID ANNOUNCE THAT HE PLANS
TO ROLL OUT A NEW COLOR CODED
VERIFICATION SYSTEM NEXT WEEK.
DO YOU THINK THAT THAT EFFORT
WILL HELP PREVENT MISINFORMATION
OR MOCK ACCOUNTS FROM PUTTING
OUT FALSEHOODS?
>> I HOPE SO BUT HIS RECORD SO
FAR ISN'T VERY GOOD.
>> HMM.
BOB BAER, WE HAVE TO LEAVE THE
CONVERSATION THERE.
ALWAYS APPRECIATE THE TIME.
THANK YOU.
>> THANK YOU.
>> OF COURSE.